And now it's the old scout master
Last week's trivia question.
Here's the answer.
It's about the World Organization of the Scouting Movement
And we asked: which country has the most scouts? okay,
So the World Organization of the Scouting Movement.
they conducted a census in 2010..
And there's 161 countries with a recognized
national scouting organization.
Which has the most?
The answer was Indonesia, with 8,103,835 scouts.
How about that?
The US was second with 5,970,203 scouts.
So Indonesia was the correct answer.
And last week I asked you to post it on Facebook
And Alan Green- who is no relation, by the way-
was there with the first correct answer,
and so he gets a copy of Mark Reyes,
the scout master's other handbook.
So we're going to try this again this week.
It'll be a little bit different,
So listen carefully,
But the prize is going to be Cliff Jacobson's
Camping's Top Secrets.
What a great book.
Now, I got this book a while back
and I thought you know, after being camping
for most of my life, that there weren't too many secrets.
he was going to show me
Cliff is smarter than me,
That's right.
About 250 pages of great camping information, techniques
gained over a lifetime of being
one of the world's premier canoe guides
and camping authors.
So that's a brand new copy of Cliff Jacobson's
Camping's Top Secrets,
Goes to our winner this week. and here's the question.
And so this is how you win this week.
You're going to go to scoutmastercgcom.
You're going to look for the trivia link.
It'll be right over in the right hand column.
Follow that link,
Send me your answer
And next Monday I'm going to do a random draw
out of all the correct answers and we'll declare a winner.
The way to enter this week's question:
go to scoutmastercgcom,
Follow the trivia link
and in next week's podcast I'll announce the winner.
Here's the question.
We all know Baden Powell held the first scout encampment
on Brown Sea Island off the coast of Great Britain
in 1907..
What was the name of the landowner
who allowed scouts to use his property
on Brown Sea Island for that first encampment?
Brown Sea Island, 1907, Baden Powell first scout encampment.
What was the name of the landowner
who allowed the scouts to use his property?
And I'll give you a hint:
His last name has two As in it.
When you find the answer, go to scoutmastercgcom,
Click the trivia link
and we'll do a random draw of all the correct answers
and announce the winner. next week
We'll get Camping's Top Secrets by Cliff Jacobs.
Hey, this is podcast number 144.
Hey, welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Greene.
First, we're going to take a look in the virtual mailbag
and we heard from Bryce this week.
He says: I took your advice to heart. this weekend
Our pack goes on a camp out. every year.
I had about 10 weeblos on the camp out
and we selected a hike in the morning
and activity stations in the afternoon.
Before we took the hike,
I told the boys to pick a leader for the weekend.
After they hashed it out amongst themselves,
I had a boy lead out for the hike.
Things went pretty well,
although some of the boys didn't listen to their leader
quite as well as I would have hoped.
Once or twice I had to reinforce the decision
the leader had made.
It was pretty awesome watching him talk to the boys,
get ideas and then choose an opinion
that both appealed to him
and the majority of the scouts.
In the afternoon
I had the leader divide the den into groups of five
and we went around and did the stations,
and after dinner I sat the boys down
and we talked about how they thought the day had gone
and what good reports and bad reports
I had gotten back what I thought had gone well,
and afterwards each boy got to talk about
the things he enjoyed most and the things he liked least.
Overall, I think the boys had fun.
It gave them a good primer into what they'll be doing
in their scouting future and a scout troop.
Thanks for all the great advice you give out.
That gave me the courage to break the mold
and let the boys have their first taste
of the patrol method.
Thanks, Bryce, I'm happy to hear that.
It sounds like he handled it really well
with the Weeblos Den.
And just a slight caveat: a little bit of caution:
In a Weeblos Den the boys aren't ready
to do youth leadership
in the same wise
that they are ready when they become boy scouts.
But
Bryce's example is a good example.
You know they can choose that leader
and the leader walks them around
and he has a lot of oversight
and input and reinforcement.
So we need to keep this kind of thing age-appropriate.
And then the reflection part
is the most important thing,
where we sit down at the end of the day
and we talk and the scouts talk
and everybody learns a little bit more
about why we're doing what we're doing.
Well, thanks for being in touch, Bryce,
And I'm glad that you're getting some help
from what we're putting out here.
Mike, who is an assistant scout master
with Troop 1434
in Potomac, Maryland,
got in touch about our post
with autism in scouting
and he said,
as I was driving my eighth grade son
to the Troop meeting, he said
that he does not like scouts when I take over.
He said that as a patrol leader
he knew that he had to call a scout
about a menu
for the next weekend.
I kind of pastored him about it
and he only did it after my prompting.
It was clear to me that I had kind of
taken over for him a little bit
and that he did not like that.
It was clear to me that I had to call
for me to hear my son's perspective
on my actions.
First of all, Mike, thanks for being in touch
and yeah, isn't that interesting.
A couple of things that come to mind:
That ride in the car
and those discussions.
boy, you're going to remember those
for a long, long time
and take advantage of them.
Those minutes to and from a meeting
or to and from a camp out-
they're golden time. I'll tell you,
We have a constant battle.
We have as parents and as scout leaders:
what do I do?
How much influence do I have?
We got a little feedback from a scout.
Didn't appreciate it very much.
That's not to say that you shouldn't do it,
but the fact that they react to it
this way helps us kind of temper
the number of times
we're going to remind them about something
and then they'll learn one of two ways:
whether we remind them
or whether they just let it go
and it doesn't work.
So we can try both ways.
It'll help.
But once again, Mike, thanks for being in touch.
Also heard from our friend, Walter Torres,
about the email we talked about last week
where we had an adult leader
who was a bit of a problem,
and as a part of the answer there
we described the steps to remove a volunteer.
So Walter said, as usual,
that was most informative and direct.
I'd like to make a suggestion.
When you make comments like that,
I say: rule, have the references
on the blog to back up your statements.
As usual, I always want more
when your podcasts are over.
So that's an excellent point
and I do try to provide as many references
as I can.
Removing a volunteer from scouting
is relatively rare
and there are some things in scouting
that we don't discuss in training very often
and they're not really commonly understood
because they are relatively rare.
but just like somebody
breaking a bone on a camping trip
is relatively rare,
and here we knock wood,
Everybody else do the same thing.
Just because that kind of event
is relatively rare doesn't mean
we don't need to know first aid.
So the information I gave you last week
about the job of the committee chair
and the charter organization representative
and the head of the charter organization
you can find in several different places
and you have to stitch it together
to get the full picture
of the services I'll send you to
and these will all be linked
on the post. that contains this podcast
on scoutmastercgcom
is a document called
Commissioner, Administration of Unit Service
and there's a little section in there
that talks about the authority
to deal with appointing
and removing volunteers
and it says this:
who has the authority to remove a volunteer?
A good rule of thumb is this:
the person or group with the authority
to remove and replace that volunteer.
You'll find the functions of
appointing volunteers
more thoroughly explained in the troop committee guidebook,
which is another good resource
and that's linked at scoutmastercgcom.
and you'll also find this
in a document called the Chartered Organization Representative
from the BSA
and it's also linked on the website
at the post that contains this podcast,
and it says this: as the Chartered Organization Representative,
you have the authority
and responsibility to hire
and fire- quote, unquote-
the leadership of the unit.
So there are some references,
that kind of back up what we said last week.
that was a very good point, Walter,
and we do always try to provide
as many references as we can
when we're discussing procedural stuff
like that or policy stuff like that.
but a good reminder from you.
So in this week's podcast,
our third and final installment of a series
about youth leader development-
and then we have an email question answer
and responsibilities- that kind of all weaves together there.
How about that?
So that ought to be enough for any podcast.
so let's get started. shall we
Scout Master's ship in seven minutes
or less?
We started talking about youth leader development
three podcasts ago
and in the first installment
we talked about the fact that youth develop
best when they are active,
when they're doing and not just watching
or not just learning about things
abstractly, but learning about it
experientially-
That our best scout youth leader training
is an active process of discovery.
In the second part we talked about
the relationships and environment
most conductive to development,
and this time around, in this last
installment, we're going to talk about
specific practices
that aid in developing leadership.
How do you actually make this happen?
So I've got a few pieces of advice for you.
First, don't wait.
If you're going to wait for your scouts to actually
be leaders before they're trusted
with real responsibility,
you're going to be waiting a long time,
and so will they.
We are developing youth leaders,
and youth leaders develop
by what-
Experiencing and doing.
So we really can't wait until we think they're ready.
We'll be developing with them,
we'll be working with them.
things will grow incrementally over time,
but we have to start,
And once we do start,
we've got to back off and let them lead.
We don't want to shout at them
or do a whole lot of hand holding.
we don't want to dog their tracks.
we want to make our advice and mentoring brief,
and it's important to realize it'll be more effective
if we make fewer statements.
this is how you should do this
and ask a lot more questions:
Well, why did you do it that way?
That's the kind of thing that we're looking for.
We're looking for an approach to this
with other adults in advisory roles.
it's a good idea, for instance,
to agree that only one
of the adult leaders
is going to direct the senior patrol leader
and that should be the scout master.
so if anybody else,
if any other adults, have concerns about what's going on,
they need to go to the
scout master or the other designated adult
and decide how it will be addressed.
I've seen
a group of adults,
a poor senior patrol leader,
ragged on a weekend
camping by being helpful,
by getting lots of directions and advice
and everything like that, naturally,
and then he gets all this conflicting advice
and everything. so we have to coordinate
with other adult leaders and say:
look, I'll be talking to the senior
patrol leader,
I'll be talking to the patrol leaders,
I'll be doing what's needed there.
if you have concerns, bring them to me first.
don't give the other youth leaders instructions.
we've discussed it so that
we're coordinated.
one of the other really practical things to do
is to respond to initiative.
respond to initiative from
youth leaders rather than
having youth leaders respond
to your initiative.
let them have their own ideas,
let them instigate
their own actions and then
respond to those, rather than
you having all the ideas.
if you ask the right questions,
you can give them ideas.
what are you doing now?
what's your job?
what's your goal here?
what's happening next?
they'll put the pieces together
slowly at first, but then they'll begin doing it on their own,
even newly minted youth leaders.
they will show initiative
if we learn to look for it,
look for the least little signs of it-
an idea, an action that shows promise-
and support it.
here's some typical expressions of initiative.
so if a patrol leader calls all his scouts
and they show up at that week's meeting,
that's a very big deal
and you need to fall
over yourself complimenting them about that,
because they know that they took an action,
they took an initiative
and it bore results
and that that was a good thing.
so you need to connect those things together for them.
let's say, the senior patrol leader
leads a patrol leader's council session
on their own for the first time.
very big deal,
very big deal.
you need to congratulate your senior patrol leader about that.
even if it was a giant mess, he did it.
it was his job and he did it.
he showed some initiative.
when a patrol shops for food
and packs it along and prepares it to go on a camping trip,
you need to make sure that you're complimentary
about it, that you pointed out,
and that you celebrate the fact that they actually made it happen.
now, that is something
that is a fairly common occurrence.
patrols make their own menu,
they shop, they get the food, they take it on the trip,
and it's so common I think
that sometimes we forget
what an important developmental step it is.
we need to recognize that,
we need to be on top of it,
we need to respond to that initiative.
a meeting or a camp out
or some kind of activity goes by without any adult involvement
in the program. we need to respond to that
and we need to make sure that they know
how well they did
so. the things that seem routine to us
but are new to youth leaders,
these are things that we can look at
as expressions of initiative
and we ought to praise them
and support them.
and we don't only do that with the scout,
but to our fellow adult volunteers
and the scouts, fellow
youth leaders,
even if they don't get everything out of it
that you think they ought to,
even if it kind of falls on its face a little bit,
even if they fail outright,
we ought to recognize initiative
every time and express
appreciation and our admiration
for that.
that's a real big encouragement to scouts.
now. we also
have to understand that there will be,
at times, a decided
lack of initiative. it may
take some real digging to find
something, something,
the least little bit of anything.
in the absence of anything good to say,
take the bad
and contrast it with the worst.
you know you may have missed that,
but at least the worst didn't happen.
you know you didn't bring a
frying pan, but at least
you brought the eggs.
and if you can't even find
anything there, if all else
fails, remember that your
youth leaders are volunteering to be
scouts. they're showing up,
they're walking through the door,
even at the worst of times,
that's something to celebrate.
glad to see you, glad you're here.
let's get to work. once we've learned
to these little
signals of initiative, we need to
observe and reflect. it's important
to reiterate that scout masters
are not bosses or commanders.
we're supporting
facilitators. okay,
we recognize and respect the authority
and the responsibility of our youth leaders.
our chief activity is not actively
advising, directing and mentoring
every moment. our role is observing
and then reflecting.
observing and reflecting.
put yourself in the role of a coach.
stay on the sidelines and off the field,
let the scouts play the game
and then reflect on their performance.
to ask afterwards. and how do you do
that? well, you ask how things went,
what they think went well, what
they could improve in next time.
honest and useful reflection
with a group of scout age boys
can maybe kind of difficult,
but be patient,
keep it to a few minutes at the most.
boys are especially sensitive
to criticism. even that kind of
good natured ribbing that they do with each other
and we sometimes get into
it can be taken the wrong way.
so watch out. the point of
reflection is guiding youth
leaders to discover what's happening,
not to tell them what's
happening, and I think that's important.
let me repeat it: the point of
reflecting is guiding
youth leaders to discover what's happening,
not for us to tell them
what's happening. so it's not an after
action report that we read.
it's a discussion
in which they describe
and discover what's going on. and this is
going to work really well if you learn to
respect the discovery process.
trial and error
and reflection is going to show
youth leaders what they don't know or don't
understand. that kind
of experience. as a powerful teacher,
five minutes of trying things out
beats five hours
of us telling them how things work.
developing youth leaders
will understand, accept
and apply training much more
readily when they see a need
for it, rather than being
told that they need it.
give them the environment to try,
observe the action,
guide a reflection
and help them discover
what they did well
and what needs a little bit of work.
if we understand how youth leaders
develop, create and maintain
the conditions that foster that
development, understand
and maintain a useful relationship
between adult volunteers and youth leaders,
and develop the skills of observation
and reflection, we'll see
our youth leaders grow in competence
and effectiveness.
This is Bob Mazzucchi,
scout executive of the Boy Scouts,
and you're listening to my buddy, Clark Green
on the Scout Master Podcast
and he is doing a fantastic job.
E-mail that is, folks,
and here's an answer
to one of your e-mails.
So this e-mail comes from
Charles Sanders, assistant scout master
with Troop 976
down in College Station, Texas.
He says: I need clarification
on Troop Bugler
counting as a position of leadership
for rank advancement.
The 2010 handbook lists
it for star and life ranks.
whoever, I've seen that information
online that contradicts this.
someone in our troop even said
when completing an Eagle app
that a scout who had previously served
in this position was not able to use it.
fortunately, it also served in another
qualifying position, so it was not a problem,
trying to prevent any future
difficulties. thanks for your advice.
well, thank you for getting in touch, Charles.
so far as the bugler
position is concerned,
it's listed in
star and life but not an eagle.
so it qualifies
for star and life- and this is after I checked
on scoutingorg
and looked at the latest iteration
of the rank requirements. but
it is not included in the acceptable
positions of responsibility for eagle.
so we need to be careful when we're looking
online because a lot of stuff can be out
of date. I always go to scoutingorg
and look for the most current information
there and
I always look in the guide to advancement.
so whatever we see online
is wrong if it doesn't coincide with the guide
to advancement or the information at scoutingorg.
let's get that clear.
so the other interesting thing
that comes out of this email that I think is
a good thing to discuss for a moment
is: there is no leadership
requirement for any rank.
I'm waiting, okay, pick yourself
up off the floor for a second. there's no leadership
requirement for any rank
other than a scout demonstrates
leadership in the eagle project,
the requirements for star life
and eagle. when they talk
about the tenured
positions, call them
positions of responsibility.
they don't call them leadership positions.
we have this common
kind of lingua franca in scouting,
where we use them interchangeably,
but they're different, and this difference
is explained very well
in the guide to advancement. in
are you ready? section 4,
point 2,
point 3,
point 4,
point 6:
yes, the guide to advancement
2011- and I'm reading directly
from it here- many suggest
this requirement-
and they're talking about the tenured
position requirements for star life and eagle-
should
call for a position of leadership
rather than simply
of responsibility,
and that's a common misunderstanding,
isn't it? we have this common misunderstanding.
alright, back to the guide.
taking and accepting responsibility,
however, is a key foundation
for leadership.
alright, I can understand that
one cannot lead effectively
without it,
and it is responsibility, so you have to be responsible
to be a leader, got it?
the requirement,
as written, recognizes
the different personalities,
talents and skill sets in all
of us. some seem
to be destined to be the leader
of the group- quote, unquote. others
provide quality support
and strong examples behind
the scenes. without this support,
the leaders in charge have little chance
for success. thus,
the work of those
support positions becomes part
of the overall leadership
effort, and I really like
that statement. I think it's very smart.
does a troop need a scribe?
well, yeah, does he need a quarter master?
absolutely a bugler. nice thing
to have. if you got a boy you can play the bugle,
great idea. historian,
librarian chaplain's aid.
these aren't intended to be up front
leader of the group. quote unquote
positions. these are positions
of responsibility. these are
support positions and a lot
of us are very, very good
at that and a lot of us are very good
at being that kind of upfront leader.
but
there's two different skill sets
there, there's two different personalities,
two different talents in that,
and that's why scouting doesn't
just limit those positions
to ones of leadership
but expands it
to positions of responsibility.
now, after I said
that there's no
leadership requirements
for any rank in scouting other than the fact
that a scout doing his
ego project demonstrates leadership,
everybody probably threw up their hands
and said: oh well, we don't do leadership development
anymore in scouting. we don't have youth leadership positions,
we don't. I guess
we're not doing that anymore. well, that's,
that's not true and you know it.
the thing is is what
we do is we recognize
these different skill sets
and personalities and talents
and we recognize them
all as being part of
a good, well rounded personality,
of being a contributing member
to our community and our society,
and we want to recognize
that their development
is an important aspect of scouting.
so, developing responsibility,
developing leadership:
they go hand in hand. and when we're looking
at that aspect of star life
and eagle, we need to understand
the definition of
positions of responsibility
and we need to apply that definition
correctly and evaluating those requirements.
so, Charles, I hope that helps.
you know, the best way for all of us
to avoid misunderstandings is to go to the guide:
guide to advancement
2011. it's easy to find out there.
it's in a pdf version. I'll link to it
on the post that contains
this podcast. everybody
involved in scouting should read through that guide
once, just once.
you don't have to study it closely,
just read through it once
and then keep it around for reference.
I go back to it all the time. I don't have it memorized,
you know, and I've probably read it
more than you have, but after reading it
now, I kind of understand the different things
that it addresses and I know
where to go when I need the information.
and I know that
most troops, after reading the guide,
are going to make some adjustments to the way
they're administering advancement, and that's a good thing.
that's something that we should be open
to do is we get smarter.
we make the way that we do things smarter right,
alright? well, I would love to hear from you,
and I'm going to tell you how to do that in
just a second.
well, thank you so much for listening.
here's how you can keep in touch.
read the scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom.
when you do that, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog
by email. you can subscribe to the
scoutmaster podcast on itunes
and when you do, leave a comment or review a rating,
that's always a nice thing to find.
you can also access the podcast
through your mobile device
on Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you can get details about how to do that
at stitchercom.
you can call in and record a shout out
to be included in a future edition of the scoutmaster podcast.
go to scoutmastercgcom
and follow the shout out link.
you can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
you can follow us at scoutmaster blog,
tweet scoutmastercg on twitter
and
find scoutmastercg on google plus.
for admittance to the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle,
please email me,
Clark Green, with your comments, questions
and wild ideas
at scoutmastercg.
at Verizonnet,
the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast are now official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
hey, it's just me.
it's just me, that's right.
no team of professionals, no million dollar facility,
just at a microphone, a laptop
and an internet account. that's all we need.
I'm talking into the microphone here,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little fun along the way.
and before we leave you,
let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pel.
Sir Robert, good luck to you
and good camping.
why? thank you, sir? until next time,
music.